make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and in
this video i want to talk about nexus
beings because the most recent episode
of wanda vision has basically
established that wanda is a nexus being
now we're largely going to keep this
confined to comics we're not really
going to be doing a whole lot of
discussion on the wanda vision show
itself what i will say
is that the idea of agatha referring to
wanda as a scarlet witch
it really looks like the mcu is
transforming the name of the title of
scarlet witch into exactly that a title
that belongs to a person who is a nexus
being as opposed to it simply just being
a moniker that scarlet witch adopted for
herself
and just kind of calling it a day uh but
focusing on the comics right focusing
strictly on the comic books here uh the
idea of a nexus being hails from what we
refer to
as the nexus of all realities now to
give you guys some perspective here when
it comes to the multiverse and marvel
comics this is a really complex thing
not in terms of its ability to
understand but in terms of how it
functions
so what you guys are aware of is the
fact that you've got a multiverse right
multiple universes all operating
essentially simultaneously
and the entirety of the multiverse and
marvel comics is largely borne by what
we call divergent timelines which is to
say
what if things had happened differently
so there's an alternate reality for
example where stephen strange never
became the sorcerer supreme where it was
somebody else right some guy named john
who's watching this video right now
congratulations john you're the sorcerer
supreme and this even applies to major
events right take for example the idea
of peter parker becoming venom what if
peter parker never stopped being venom
or you know peter parker in his black
symbiote suit spider-man fans like to
split hairs and say actually he's
not technically venom but he was
possessed by the venom symbiote he was
basically venom if we look at that and
we say
what if peter parker never lost the
symbiote there's a timeline for that
what this all basically means
is that nexus beings are supremely
powerful because if you look at the idea
of the multiverse this comes in a couple
different forms you have things like the
omniversal development court
and the omniversal matrix who oversees
the omniversal development court and
their job is to basically make sure
that across all the timelines that like
mutants come into existence around the
same time that like every universe has a
version of the avengers the people with
superpowers in general start to emerge
just different things like that and the
omniversal magistrix oversees all that
and makes sure that everything's going
the way it's supposed to uh that's what
happened
in the old mad jim jasper storyline
where uh where you ended up having
saturnine who realized that there was a
universe where nobody had powers and
when they tried to make that happen
it was revealed that jim jaspers had
basically killed everybody with powers
and then used his reality warping
abilities to totally distort and destroy
that universe
uh but nonetheless you know you have
things like what's called the nexus of
all realities which comes from the
florida everglades believe it or not
that's actually where you ended up
having howard the duck introduced into
the in the marvel comics where you
basically go to the florida everglades
and there's a being there called the man
thing
and that he'll essentially test you but
he'll actually touch you and if you feel
fear
you'll burn at the touch of the man
thing but if you're fearless you'll be
able to basically pass him
and then go through the the florida
everglades into the nexus of all
realities and then you can access any
universe from there but there's multiple
ways to enter in and out of the universe
that's leaving out things like the
imcron crystal and stuff like that
there's a bunch of different ways to do
it what makes nexus beings so
significant here
is that in every universe you have guys
like doctor strange or you have the
ancient one or you have brother voodoo
you have people out there who can use
magical energy but unlike those guys all
the mystic energy that exists in one
universe including all the pocket
dimensions like asgard
like uh like the dark dimension from
dormammu and places like that they all
kind of flow through that person and so
what it means is that if you have
somebody like doctor strange for example
to kind of give you guys a comparison
here between someone like the the
scarlet witch who's a nexus being and
someone like dr strange
that doctor strange uses the powers of
other people right so doctor strange
borrows powers from like the vashanti
which is where he gets like 80
of his powers from he borrows powers
from sidorak the guy who turned the
juggernaut into the juggernaut and he
uses those to spawn crimson bands and a
litany of other beings out there
but not every source of magic that's
available to be used
can be used by steven strange and so
steven strange were a guy who were
walking through a hallway of doors and
behind
each one of these doors is a source of
magic he can tap into some of those
doors are just locked
and he doesn't have a key for it a
person who's a nexus being has a master
key they can open every single door they
can access every single source of energy
that exists out there right
dimensions that are composed of pure
energy that they can manipulate they can
control
they can use it for their own ends this
also comes by way of the fact
that their ability to alter timelines
is something that comes from their
ability to manipulate or to affect the
probability of a universe unfolding
in timelines that can diverge from that
particular action right so if you look
at the early part
early powers of the scarlet witch she
had what was called probability
manipulation which is to say in one of
the early stories for example they were
fighting ultron and using her powers
like ultron like a portion of him
short-circuited and it was like okay so
that's how the avengers were able to
find their opening and they defeated
ultron it was by virtue of her powers
that that happened had she not been
there that never would have taken place
ultron probably would have killed the
heroes and then you would have had age
of ultron published
30 years before it was actually written
by bendis in them right so uh
the whole point behind this is that
because the multiverse exists as a
result of realities diverging off and
because those realities diverge off
based on changes to the timeline
a person who's a nexus being can quite
literally create alternate timelines
and that's why groups like the time
variance authority keep such a close eye
on those individuals who are nexus
beings because the time variance
authority is to make sure people don't
screw with the timeline and mess things
up and so if scarlet witch came into the
full understanding
of what she was capable of and was able
to manipulate 100
of all the various mystical energies
that were out there then a few things
would happen
one she would become equal to eternity
and power those you guys who don't know
what that means
eternity is a being who is able to who's
the living embodiment of the universe
now he's not the top dog
if you have an infinity gauntlet you can
overpower eternity and i would dare say
that if she reached the full totality of
being a nexus being and was able to 100
control the the all the mystical
energies that exist in her universe
she'd probably become equivalent to an
infinity gauntlet right the ability to
manipulate time space the mind
reality itself all that kind of stuff
the other thing that would happen
is she could arbitrarily create
alternate realities right she could just
create them on a whim she could say okay
so like this is a series of events that
have happened let's change that let's do
something else instead and literally
reality the universe would just become a
bobble in her hand she could just
change it and alter it and do whatever
she wants with it but
there are huge checks and balances in
place to make sure she can't do that
we've already talked about the time
variance authority and the time variance
authority would basically neutralize her
right like in that case
if she was doing that they would
basically they have the ability to
neutralize people who are nexus beings
and they would do that they would find
her they would take her down
and then in turn they would like fix the
timeline quote unquote and that would
basically be it but then there are other
things as well like the living tribunal
the living tribunal exists to make sure
that mystical balance is maintained
throughout any one particular universe
and across the entirety of the
multiverse so that's why you couldn't
have
doctor strange leave his universe and
then go to an alternate reality
and say i'm gonna be doctor strange here
and we'll have two sorcerer supremes in
the universe that violates the laws
the mystic laws of the universe and so
the living tribunal would step in
and then say okay stephen strange either
you go back to your native universe or i
will wipe you from existence and then
replace you with a new source or supreme
in your universe
and then go forward accordingly uh if if
the scarlet witch as a nexus being were
to
arbitrarily start going through and
creating divergent timelines and just
throwing off all the mystical balance in
her universe then the living tribunal
would step in assuming the time variance
authority did not
and call it a day right basically
neutralize her powers or force her to
obey and to set things back to the way
they were before
because she'd have no she'd have no
power over the living tribunal that's
not gonna happen i don't care how
powerful any nexus being is out there
none of them will ever come close to the
power of the living tribunal it just
doesn't work that way
uh literally the tribunal's job is to
safeguard the multiverse right so you
know barring some beings out there like
the beyonders very few people
if any are going to be able to come
close to the tribunal's power but
the biggest issue that you have when it
comes to the idea of nexus beings
is that marvel's never fully fleshed out
the idea and that's the biggest struggle
right the idea of a nexus being has
existed in marvel comics for decades but
they've never done anything with it
right they've never really
explained it in any super concrete
in-depth way that applies to scarlet
witch
as she exists now right so the idea of
scarlet witch being a nexus being has
never been adequately explained in
relation to like the events of the house
of m
or anything like that that marvel hasn't
done that they probably will now
in marvel comics because of what's going
on with the mcu but it's never really
happened before the only thing that we
as comic book fans know is that
it's a thing that exists out there that
a person who is a nexus being has the
potential to become the most powerful
being throughout the entirety of the
multiverse possibly even achieving power
greater than that of eternity and
potentially becoming equal to
a infinity gauntlet in scope uh they can
communicate with other beings out there
who are nexus beings but those
individuals who are nexus beings across
the whole multiverse no two are alike
meaning no two have the exact same power
that some can control their their magic
in in
some ways someone can control it in
other ways so like necromancy different
things along those lines but that
they're not
identical across the board so it's not
like a jonathan hickman
molecule man owen reese kind of
situation for those of you guys who
understand the reference
that's not what we're talking about
modern humanoid rhys is stupid powerful
right he's a multiversal force of power
i mean the guy could just wipe out
universes with a wave of his hand but
like that's not what we're talking about
it's not that exact same kind of concept
it's one of these things that marvel's
just never fully fleshed out hopefully
they will but that's what makes a video
like this
explaining nexus being so difficult is
because it's like trying to it's like
trying to catch smoke in your hands to a
degree right it's an intangible concept
that's never really been solidified in
marvel
it's more of a title that belongs to
wanda maximoff that doesn't really seem
to have any direct correlation with
anything she's recently done of
significance and like that's it so with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you guys are new
here to comments explain make sure you
guys hit the sub button to become part
of the rob core if you guys enjoyed this
video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
[Music]
peace
you